Should I put this in? Wait, wait, Remy,
no, that's not it. Look carefully. It's
not that, it's this. Isn't it time to do that? I
saw the recipe. Look at my hand.
Sakura. It
says salt. Should I use it?
Salt.  If it says so, I'll probably do it.Both of us are
mixing things up in a dirty way.Sengoku
fans are still mixing the ingredients.It's time to
finish class.Sengoku-kun, you can
cut up the vegetables and do that.Me
?
[Music]
Carelessly.  Accidentally heading
to Kamakura If you're pointless, you've already sworn that
Remi won't do it if you use a knife.But
Remi also wants to cut vegetables, but not for
now.The scene just now is slightly traumatic.
[Music] Just
mix this carefully and slowly.That's
it.  Don't do anything else, just throw the
bandage and cut it.